the United States faces security threats
from multiple states and groups and in
multiple regions of the world but it
does so at a time when public opinion is
less supportive American efforts to
address those threats than any time in
decades since the inconclusive wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan and the 2008
financial crash America's appetite for
global security leadership has dropped
dramatically when he entered office
President Obama pledged to rebuild the
country by moving away from nation
building abroad the nation-building at
home and use the rest to do some
nation-building right here at home
likewise when running for president
Donald Trump questioned the wars America
had been fighting and the value of
America's alliances abroad dragged us
into foreign wars that have made us less
safe
both presidents believe that afford we
mean American military presence is
costly and at times counterproductive
evolving us in conflicts and
competitions with other powers that are
not they argued in our national interest
but the policies of retrenchment have
not brought us greater peace and
stability in the cases of Russia China
and Iran efforts to normalize relations
have not lessen tensions to the contrary
each nation has read US policies and
cuts to defense spending and signs of
American weakness and decline if
anything American retrenchment has
fueled ambitions of Russia China and
Iran not appease them as a result we are
facing growing uncertainty in three
regions of the world Europe Asia
in the middle-east that american state
craft has long understood to be the
linchpins of global peace and security
however that begs the question of why
the United States should care now after
all the threats posed by the three
states are far from American shores some
even argue that the u.s. might concede
greatest way in a region to these rising
powers in the expectation that they will
then become satisfied powers but history
suggests otherwise new levels of
dominance in a region inevitably
introduce new interests and new concerns
for the rising power moreover states
that neighbor the rising peril will have
an interest in pushing back against such
dominance or if unable to do so
appeasing the rising power in either
case the rising power will have created
the kinds of tensions and instability
that inevitably prevent a rising power
from becoming a satisfied power the
security dilemma posed by a rising power
that's further fueled by the specific
character of that state in this case all
three countries Russia China and Iran
are illiberal and present themselves as
challengers to the Democratic West by
their very nature they rest uneasy in
the world and how dominated by liberal
trade and politics and where the
dominant power is still the United
States it's undeniable that American
prosperity and security are enhanced
when America is the dominant power in
Europe Asia and the Middle East however
with the fall of the Soviet Union in
1991 America took its eye off the ball
as a result some Americans started to
believe in the end of history the idea
that the ideological conflicts in the
19th and 20th century had come to a
close others simply wanted the peace
dividend that came with the end of the
Cold War with no serious challengers to
threaten American security support for
military spending and global deployments
eroded Americans continue to profess the
values of global leadership but they
thought the nation could do as much
while shrinking the military and
reducing its overseas presence
most Americans believe that 9/11 changed
things
stirring Americans from their delusions
about the dawn of an era of absolute
security but despite substantial
investments in fighting the wars in Iraq
and in Afghanistan success of u.s.
presidents declined to make the
long-term investments necessary to
modernize the military as a result the
American military is losing its
qualitative edge and is too small to
address the various global challenges
and now faces once the envy of the world
America's military can no longer
confidently shock-and-awe
its adversaries to restore the world
order Congress and the White House must
adopt a long term perspective the u.s.
cannot focus on what changes threats and
technologies instead America must
recognize what remains constant American
security interest and political
principles defending the liberal order
is in our interest and it is best done
with allies who in exchange for American
security guarantees have by and large
buy out the United States to construct a
global order that is both in our image
and to our advantage to learn more about
my take on national security and
American global leadership check out the
link to my new book rise of the
revisionist in the description below
also let us know what other topics you'd
like a EEI scholars to cover on rethink
tank and be sure to subscribe for more
videos and research from AEI